all right we're back for yet another
video uh today in true work from home
style i am going to be recording in my
underwear unfortunately you guys don't
get a sneak peek yet but perhaps is an
incentive for you all to subscribe
i'll do some dirty underwear shots at a
thousand but okay actually though let's
talk about the video for today which is
going to be chain replication
fun fact the guy who actually wrote this
paper was my operating systems professor
which is pretty sweet
but uh yeah let's talk about his work
okay chain replication so what is it
unlike some of the other replication
schemes that we've spoken about
um in 2004 the original paper for chain
replication came out and basically said
here's a way that we're going to achieve
both strong consistency and high
availability while maintaining pretty
high throughput
then there's kind of the subsequent
paper that came out called crack craq
and basically that even provides more
read throughput so i'm going to go
through how all of these processes work
so for starters let's talk about chain
replication rights
imagine we have
this kind of chain of database nodes
right so we have a head two replicas and
a tail and then we have a client and
what the client does is it goes and
first writes to the head of the list
the head is then going to propagate
those rights such that the head passes
to the first replica first replica
passes to the second replica the second
replica passes to the tail which is the
last node in that list
once the tail receives the right it's
going to go ahead and acknowledge that
message and pass it back through the
chain so as you can see now we have a
chain of acknowledgements going back
through those replicas
once the head receives the
acknowledgement for that right it's
going to go back to the client and say
good job the right was successful it's
propagated through the chain
okay
in terms of reads all reads are actually
going to be made from the tail and so
this is kind of the unique part of chain
replication that ensures strong
consistency
remember that the second a client hears
that it's right is successful or
committed it means that that right is
actually in the tail so by reading from
the tail we can see only up-to-date data
okay so let's talk about failover
because i mentioned that this schema was
particularly high availability well why
is that
generally speaking we're not using
something like a gossip protocol here
because that has all sorts of potential
issues where you know if two links can't
communicate with each other one might
think that the other's down and the
other might think you know the first is
down and then the the chain becomes
completely babbled so what you do is you
use an external coordination service
like zookeeper which we've discussed in
the past that uses some sort of
consensus algorithm to determine which
nodes are running and which nodes are
not running
so anyways here's what happens in
certain failure scenarios if a head
fails then you go ahead and just promote
the head's next node to the head because
that's going to have all pretty much all
the rights that the head had it may have
some uncommitted ones but it's not a big
deal if uncommitted rights are lost
because the client never received an
acknowledged message for that
if the tale has failed then we're going
to go ahead and start executing reads
from the replica right before the tail
so that works well because again that
should have all the rights that the tail
had because it's quite literally giving
them to the tail so we're not losing any
data and then if any middle node has
failed basically we would do the same
thing that we might do in terms of
removing a node from a linked list and
we would just go ahead and have to kind
of remove it from the chain
and
you know take each adjacent replica and
make sure that the chain is put back
together and then pass the rights from
the left replica to the right one and
make sure everything is updated
okay in terms of the analysis of chain
replication and how it's good and how
it's not so great
it's really strong or amazing that there
is strong consistency and linear
linearizability in this type of
replication schema we have a total
ordering of rights everything is
eventually going to be reaching the tail
in some specified order which is great
additionally rights are going to be less
expensive in single leader replication
this is because even though every single
write goes to the head and kind of in
the same sense every single write goes
to the leader in single leader
replication
the leader in single leader replication
is sending all of those rights to every
single replica whereas in chain
in chain replication
there's only one write being sent from
the head at a time so you know those
operations are actually less expensive
we're less likely to overload the head
node
and then also if we're looking at raft
or paxos kind of the same deal happens
where you have that leader and it's
sending out a bunch of network calls at
the same time
the biggest con is obviously the read
throughput is limited to just one note
i i put unless sharded here on the slide
and that's because you know if we have
multiple chains for each partition so
you know one chain per partition then
you can actually increase read
throughput but even still you know you
can't just say oh we have the same type
of data being served from you know these
two chains that doesn't work basically
if you want to serve some data you're
limited to one chain for it and as a
result you're limited to the read
throughput of just the tail node and
then additionally it's very easy to have
bottlenecks meaning that one slow node
in the chain is going to slow down the
entire process of rights
because rights have to go through every
single replica
okay now let's talk about crack so crack
is kind of
a modification to chain replication that
allows you to achieve much higher rate
not right throughput read throughput by
taking reads from any of the replicas so
how can we actually do that
well let's imagine first that we have
this kind of chain replication set up
right here and then it's going to start
in a consistent state
so everything that you see right here
every replica has the key jordan and the
value sexy and right now see look at one
and clean one is known as the version
number and clean i'll describe in a
second
so let's imagine now that i perform a
right
now instead of jordan being sexy he's
hot so the head is going to take this
right and it's going to increment the
version number
and it's going to put the parameter
dirty next to it dirty basically means
that the right has yet to be
acknowledged so it hasn't received the
acknowledgement back from the next
replica
hence this is considered a dirty right
and we'll see what that kind of means
for the future
okay so now we're going to go ahead and
propagate that right through and all the
replicas are going to have dirty as
their state for um you know version
number two
until
the right eventually reaches the tail
node the tail node can't have any dirty
rights because it's supposed to be the
source of truth so it goes and
overwrites the clean key which was sexy
and now has version 2 for hot
it's going to start sending back
acknowledgements now and as the
acknowledgements go through every single
replica they're going to say okay now i
can finally label hot as clean
and as a result since this key is now
clean and or the key value pair is clean
i can go ahead and get rid of the older
versions of that
so now replica 3 is going to say hot to
clean replica 2 has hot too clean
replica 1 has hot to clean
okay great so that all makes sense but
how do we actually do reads how does
this increase read throughput
well there are basically two possible
scenarios
so imagine we're trying to read a key
and that's going to go to a replica
where the highest version number
available of the key is clean and
basically so as you can see since we're
in a consistent state here
hot to clean is the same amongst all
replicas so it means that you know say
the read went to the second replica here
it's guaranteed that it's going to
return hot and we know that um that's
the state that the tail has because it's
labeled as clean
however
what if i went and made the right thick
and it got to the second replica and
then we tried to read from the second
replica
well something now is going to happen
the second replica is going to say oh
shoot now i realize that thick is
actually a dirty right and as a result
of that i have to reach out to the tail
to see what the the greatest value of
the current clean write is in order to
go ahead and return that
so it's going to go ahead and contact
the tail node and what's going to happen
is the tail node says oh actually the
highest
version i currently have says that the
value is hot so replica is going to say
okay i'm just going to return hot now
you might say to yourself here
oh well just looking at this why can't
we just return the clean right well we
can't return the clean right because
it's possible that thick did actually
get written on tail however the
acknowledgement just hasn't been sent
back to the replica yet and as a result
of that then we would return hot too and
you know that thinking that was the
right value when in reality the tail had
already processed the right thick so
ultimately it is important that we
actually end up reaching out to the tail
to get the proper version number
okay so in terms of the evaluation of
crack or the analysis
in read heavy workloads this is actually
going to be super useful the majority of
the reads are going to be clean and as a
result the read throughput should scale
almost linearly to the number of
replicas
if there are a ton of writes well we're
going to have a lot more
dirty reads and eventually have to
contact the tail mode much more that
being said we would have been contacting
the tail node every single time anyway
and this still does take some load off
the tail node because instead of sending
back a potentially super large file over
the network to the client the tail node
just sends a version number back to
another replica which it's probably
closer in proximity to and the version
number is going to be smaller than
potentially a large file
so even though crack still does suffer
from the same problems as chain
replication in terms of one node
potentially acting as a bottleneck
using this allows for pretty high read
throughputs in a chain replication
scheme as well as still the ability to
maintain strong consistency
okay so in conclusion it's pretty cool
that we finally discovered like a high
availability
strongly consistent replication schema
that can achieve relatively
you know high throughput
that being said um you know it isn't
used a ton in practice but there are
some systems that use it i think amazon
still ends up using it in something
called aurora
but
even though it's probably not the most
useful thing to know about chain
replication in something like a systems
design interview i think that it might
very much impress your interviewer if
you're able to kind of bring up chain
replication as an option you know if you
ever might need strong consistency
obviously one way to do strong
consistency is to deal with um you know
something like a consensus algorithm
like paxos or raft and then you know
just use sync commands in order to
achieve strong consistency or you know
putting your reads in the log however
again that really overloads that one
liter node and in comparison chain
replication kind of spreads out that
load and so it's interesting to kind of
have that discussion
anyways guys i know this video was kind
of short i hope it was useful though and
i think i'm going to start talking about
object storage and cdns in the next